hallo mein name ist will kann ich
erzähle euch heute ein paar fakten über
mich weil ich das ja noch nie gemacht
habe 20 banken über mich videomarkt 20
fakten über meine dummheit 20 fakten
über mich ich habe mir einfach mal 27
fakten aufgeschrieben
fragt mich nicht warum sache nummer 1
ich bin 20 jahre alt geworden vor 12 323
ich sehe aber irgendwie immer noch aus
wie 5 und wurde auch letztens noch im
supermarkt gefragt ob ich wirklich schon
16 sei ja vielleicht liegt es daran dass
ich mich auch so benehmen als wäre ich
führe ich bin noch nie von einem höheren
wasser schwimmbad sprungturm schritt
gesprungen als drei meter höhe
ich weiß nicht warum es hat sich einfach
nie die chance ergeben dass wir bei
einem fünf meter turm standen der
wirklich geöffnet hatte ich glaube aber
ich würde mich auch nicht trauen von
fünf metern runter zu springen weil bei
meinem glück würdig mit dem
bauchklatscher aufkommen und sterben
ich wollte vor drei tagen ein paar
kisten fan zum supermarkt bringen und
als ich dann im supermarkt stand an der
maschine ist mir aufgefallen dass ich
den fans zu hause vergessen habe ich
trinke nur stilles wasser
es ist egal was von wasser dass es hier
setzt auch gerade spiel ich trinke nur
stilles wasser wenn es mit kohlensäure
ist es irgendwie man so keine ahnung ich
mag das irgendwie nicht ich habe mir vor
zwei jahren eine review gekauft und
damit bisher insgesamt vier mal gespielt
ich weiß ich weiß nicht warum eigentlich
ist es nämlich ganz neues ich hasse kfc
denken
ich mag ja sehr gerne autos und als ich
damals meinen führerschein gemacht habe
ich direkt zum fahrsicherheits
rennfahrer shit training gemacht das war
halt in so einer abgesperrten autobahn
raststätte an seinem riesigen parkplatz
wo das alles veranstaltet direkt daneben
beim kfc und das war das erste mal dass
beckham sie war wirklich mit 18 jahren
hat mir dann diesen fetten pot chicken
wings bestellt zusammen mit ihnen die
meister beim call small und micro und in
einem chicken wing war einfach so eine
kleine feder noch dran
deswegen hasse ich cave sie ich bin vor
fünf monaten in eine neue wohnung
gezogen und ich habe mir dann eine
outdoor couch gekauft für draußen und
ich habe die bis heute nicht ausgepackt
ich weiß nicht warum ich zocke nahezu
nie
das einzige was ich sage mal regelmäßig
zog ins fifa 16 und regelmäßig heißt bei
mir dann so alle drei wochen mal gegen
den kumpel der irgendwie zu gast es bei
mir meine schwester fängt sich daran die
haare zu führen also ich weiß nicht ob
das mikro das irgendwie kompensieren
kann sonst fragt euch nicht wieso da
sonst immer wenn ich aufnehme emine
neunte sache mein leben besteht derzeit
nur aus stress weil zehnte sache ich
mache derzeit ein praktikum in
düsseldorf ich produziere täglich
youtube-videos wo mich jedes video so
circa vier stunden braucht schreibe
nebenbei eine praktikums arbeit über das
praktikum und ich mache nebenbei noch
ein studium fragt mich nicht wie man das
unter einen hut kriegt die
nahrungsmittel bzw
essen fast food whatever was ich am
meisten mag ist pizza und burrito ich
könnte jeden tag mich nur davon ernähren
ich hab sogar letztes tatsächlich mal
pizza die früchte meiner mutter
antwortet in whatsapp übels oft mit
meinem gesicht als mim
hier ein kleiner ausschnitt mein
aktueller whatsapp status lautet live
so sehr in der neuesten top du was weiß
ich wollte nur auch einen klugen spruch
als status weil alle ja könnte ich nehme
mir auf ich hasse es videos aufzunehmen
wenn ich bei meiner familie bin jeder
hat halt irgendwie von whatsapp staates
mein gott beliefen your dreams du denn
aus diesen dicken make it happen das
faktisch alles voll ab deswegen ich weiß
nicht wieso anderen status macht es
einfach ihr müsst nicht so ein status
haben und was zu machen auch immer so jo
freunde motiviert mich mal dazu joggen
zu gehen was ein scheiß wenn du joggen
in willst dann geh verdammt noch mal
joggen
ich war bisher siebenmal in london in
england und bilder später unbedingt
wohnen das ist ein riesiges ziel von mir
es gibt ja möglichkeiten dass man in der
stadt einfach notwendig monat wurde dann
würde ich folgen einfach mal nach 19
monaten pc mitnehmen da videos machen da
ein bisschen praktikum machen nach
berlin ziehen für ein monat dann
abgießen für monat dann nach timbuktu
ich habe das gefühl dass obwohl ich
einen youtuber bin überhaupt nicht in
das klischee reinpassen weil mir kommst
du vor jeder lädt zum video sei von
seinen wohnungen hoch und kulturen und
auto videos und jeder fertigen porsche
und hat eine fette geile wohnung und so
viel geld und ec gesteckt und so viel
ich nehme videos mit seiner schrott
kamera von vor fünf jahren auf und sorry
wo wir gerade bei youtube sind die
schauer keinen einzigen deutschen
youtuber keinen einzigen deutschen use
of war sah ich schaue keinen einzigen
deutschen youtuber die einzigen kanäle
die ich regelmäßig verfolge sind im kern
george casey leiste teilweise
ricco war mister brown mehr tatsächlich
nicht ich schlafe derzeit
durchschnittlich fünf stunden pro nacht
ich wurde mal von einem fan girl so
krass umarmt es ziemlich umgesetzt hat
immer noch blaue flecken davon
backpulver 19 viele leute sagen ich bin
dumm bin ich aber nicht
oder ich wusste bis zu meinem abitur
nicht was ich danach machen will
also macht euch keine sorgen wenn ihr
irgendwelche zukunftsängste haben ein
handy hat an allen stellen machen wo es
irgendwie geht hab ich jetzt zwar eine
hülle darum allerdings ist die auch
schon hier voll zerbrochen und hier auch
an silvester als ein kompletter sticht
ich mein handy durchgegangen von ganz
oben bis nach ganz unten durch ich
wollte niemand das erkennt aber hier
unten ist auch ein stück herausgebrochen
das war an karneval direkt als das handy
mit der post an kam habe ich gedacht er
hat gesagt dass er so ein geiles glas
erich lassen einfach mal fallen und
setzte das glas dabei ist was hier aus
den seiten tatsächlich auch
rausgebrochen hier ist ebenfalls was aus
der seite rausgebrochen und außerdem hat
mein handy auch nur noch 30 prozent der
eigentlich angepriesenen akkulaufzeit
weil ich's mal im kühlschrank vergessen
habe für eine stunde lang nummer 23 dass
sie es nicht fakt nummer 23 sondern fakt
nummer 22
fakt 123 ich hasse alle louie vito
produkte ich finde es sieht einfach nur
scheiße aus und es ist viel zu teuer und
ich verstehe nicht wie man damit
rumlaufen kann das sind einfach diese
typischen produkte wo man nur mit
rumläuft und anderen zu zeigen hey guck
mal ich habe geld für so was
und das finde ich so scheiße so eine
einstellung natürlich könnte man jetzt
bemängeln jolo kalou als auch ein iphone
und könntest dir auch irgendwie nokia
handy rum liegen haben ja aber dieses
iphone gibt mir funktion die ich mit
einem anderen produkt nicht habe und so
einen editor tasche eine ganz andere
tasche nehmen
was genau so viel schrecken ich mein
okay ist es geschmackssache falls es
jemand mark in ordnung aber dessen
fakten über mich und ein fakt über mich
jetzt halt es ist überhaupt einfach nur
scheiße und hässlich finde ich kurz mir
meine zähne eigentlich immer länger als
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 527 weil ich dann immer
am handy bilder dann putzig sony mit dem
handy und dann mein portemonnaie ist
sechs jahre alt fällt überall
auseinander bundes irgendwie mit sechs
jahren älter als mein geistiges alter
wenn meine eltern mir im urlaub oder so
10 euro gegeben haben um brötchen für
die ganze familie zu holen und ich
beispielsweise nur acht euro beim bäcker
bezahlt habe ich einfach zwei euro
behalten
ich glaube ich schuld meinen eltern ca
4000 euro pakt nummer 27 ich möchte
später zwei kinder haben und am liebsten
einen jungen also ein sohn und eine drei
bis vier jahre jüngere tochter
das wäre so wunsch familien denken das
war es mit diesen 27 fakten weil mich
wenn es euch gefallen hat würde ich mich
über eine bewertung freuen bei welchen
fakten nimmt ihr genauso ihr könnt ja
mal die kommentare schreiben 127 und an
sich auch odernähe als maultier mehr
wirklich erfahren wollt oder fällt die
andere ideen für ihr live videos fürs
wochenende habt schreibt mir das gerne
und in die kommentare und wir sehen uns
wir sehen uns eigentlich jetzt gerade
aber irgendwann sehen uns bestimmt noch
mal wieder